pues efectivamente la casa blanca ha
ordenado completar aparte del muro
fronterizo entre eeuu y méxico y se
trata del sector yuma ya que el gobierno
norteamericano considera que por ese
lugar ha habido una gran afluencia de
migrantes en los últimos tiempos de
hecho el presidente joe biden tanto en
la campaña electoral como cuando llegó a
la presidencia de eeuu se comprometió a
paralizar todos los proyectos que se
habían llevado a cabo por parte de su
antecesor donald trump sin embargo ahora
el departamento de seguridad nacional
asegura que hay un problema de seguridad
fronteriza y es que muchos de estos
migrantes pueden resbalar o incluso
ahogarse a su paso por el río colorado
hay que tener en cuenta que en los
últimos entre enero y junio se llevaron
a cabo 160.000 detenciones lo que supone
pues cuatro veces más que en el periodo
que en el mismo periodo del año anterior
muchos de estos migrantes lo que hacen
es llegar al ácido mexicana de algodones
y de ahí puedes pasar prácticamente con
cierta facilidad hasta a eeuu para ser
detenidos por la patrulla fronteriza
muchos de estos migrantes son por cierto
venezolanos y colombianos que pues
llegan hasta la ciudad mexicana de
mexicali en avión y luego toman un taxi
hasta la frontera de eeuu